president Trump's former personal
attorney Michael Cohen pleaded guilty in
federal court today to lying to Congress
Cohen conceded that he was intentionally
wrong he lied about the dates of an
abortive Moscow real estate deal when he
testified to the Senate Intelligence
Committee last year Cohen's plea was of
course big news on cable television the
president responded to it as well he
called Cohen quote weak and quote not a
very smart person
well it's objectively true of course
it's also worth asking why anyone would
hire a week dumb lawyer someday we'll
get to the bottom of that but for now
let's consider what we have just learned
about how Washington works
apparently it's now an enforceable
felony to lie to the US Congress on one
level that is good news we should take
our own laws
seriously functional countries do that
nations in decline set up sanctuary
cities and ignore their own borders nor
is it implausible that Michael Cohen
might have broken this law or really any
other law nobody who knows him is
shocked by the allegation if Cohen was
accused of running a cannibalism ring
you'd have to at least take the charge
seriously anything is possible with that
guy so three cheers for Law & Order
the problem is if you're going to
enforce statutes you have to enforce
them fairly and evenly the law has to
apply to everyone
otherwise it's not really the law it's a
political weapon Michael Cohen is facing
five years in prison for telling
Congress something that he knew was
false how often does that happen in
Washington if you watch c-span you know
the answer
constantly all the time there are almost
never consequences by the way according
to one study between the second world
war in 2007 a total of only six people
were convicted of lying to Congress six
people in 60 years in other words the
law is not enforced and that's why
people break it so often
watch this sworn testimony from 2013
this is not someone you haven't heard of
this is the then Director of National
Intelligence Jim clapper assuring the
Congress under oath that the NSA
absolutely does not spy on American
citizens does the NSA collect any time
of data at all on millions or hundreds
of millions of Americans no sir it does
not not wittingly yeah
clapper lied he's a liar there's no
debate about that and yet he wasn't
charged for lying under oath in fact
clapper got richer after he retired CNN
hired him as an analyst pretty much the
same thing happened in Jim Comey the
former FBI director in 2017 Comey
claimed again under oath that he had
never been an anonymous source for news
stories while he worked at the FBI watch
him tell that lie to the Congress
director Comey have you ever been an
anonymous source in those reports about
matters relating to the Trump
investigation or the Clinton
investigation never have you ever otter
eyes someone else at the FBI to be an
anonymous source in news reports about
the Trump investigation or the Clinton
investigation no yeah well according to
commis longtime deputy who would now and
that would be former FBI deputy director
Andrew McCabe what Comey said on the
tape you just saw is totally untrue so
call me lied to Congress but nobody
cared Jim Comey went on to get rich as a
pundit selling his book the same people
rooting for Michael Cohen's destruction
for lying consider Jim Comey a hero and
then there's former CIA director John
Brennan Brennan lies constantly that's
well documented in 2011 for example
Brennan claimed that drone strikes
overseas had never to his knowledge
killed a single non combatant that was a
total crock in 2014 Brennan lied and
said the CIA had not broken into the
computers of Senate staffers and then
last year under oath before Congress
Brennan said this you know if the bureau
ever relied on the steel dossier as any
as part of any court filings
applications petitions pleadings I have
no awareness did the CIA rely on it no
it was not in any way used as a basis
for the intelligent that was
yeah that's a total lie a fragrant lie
and a significant one about something
that affects the life of this country
and yet you know how the story ends
Brennan was never charged with a felony
for lying to the Congress in fact just
the opposite
Washington rewarded him Brennan is now
an analyst for NBC News he could be on
the air tonight telling you why it's so
vitally important that Michael Cohen was
charged with lying to Congress because
we really can't have that rule of law
rule of law blah-blah-blah-blah-blah
jirisan theme here that connects all
these stories yes there is one and it's
simple the well-connected can do pretty
much whatever they want they can lie to
the Congress with impunity and they do
they can lobby for foreign governments
without bothering to register and they
do if they're rich enough they can even
I don't know molest children without
being seriously punished ask Jeffrey
Epstein he did that none of this by the
way is a defense of Michael Cohen that
guy's a creep he may very well wind up
in jail but if Cohen does wind up in
jail let's hope he's just the first in a
long series of prosecutions if the law
is applied to Michael Cohen that it has
to be applied to people who have lied
about things that actually matter